back to the roots gehen sie mit ihrem
neuen album wo es beginnt die madsen
sascha und sebastian madsen bei ihr zu
gast und erklären warum musik manchmal
extrem sport ist und warum perfekt
manchmal ziemlich langweilig sein kann
das jetzt im dorf ist astarloza ja gut
gut bisschen kopfschmerzen ganz bisschen
woher kommt das ich glaub unten hier im
backstage ist ein bisschen dicke luft
meister ja da wird gekocht und irgendwie
kommt da schwer die luft von oben rein
ist 108 rechner sind an was glaube ich
auch ein bisschen in der luft ca
ihr habt also nicht so ein tagesablauf
vorm konzert der euch so langsam in
watte gepackt daraufhin wird doch so ein
bisschen 'schon also leidlich ist dann
der soundcheck der jetzt gerade war der
macht einen schon mal so ein bisschen
was gemeint ist gerade namen sollen so
kurzen pass weg
wenn du dich einsatz gehabt hast du
gesangsunterricht vorgenommen oder mal
nachher oder mittendrin mal ich hatte
ein paar stunden die auch ganz hilfreich
waren wir dann gezeigt wurde wurde der
ton einig herkommen soll der und ich hab
früher wirklich den fehler gemacht vor
den konzerten dachte ich dachte ich
müsste mich ein brüllen auch mit
mietrecht beim vorm konzert ein schon
heiser totaler quatsch und jetzt habe
ich das glück dass unsere keyboarderin
elisa dass die selber gesangsunterricht
hat schon seit jahren und einige übungen
gezeigt hat und wir machen dann immer so
eine halbe stunde oder so übungen zu
zweit und das ist es dann auch das ist
der der große trick
mutter zu kommen habt ihr schon mal den
idealzustand erreicht also den
idealzustand wo er sagt bot das war das
hammermäßig konzert weil wir so
fokussiert waren auf das was alles
passiert ist
wir haben jetzt auch noch mal gemerkt
dass das wir ganz schwer abhängig vom
publikum sehr und wir haben jetzt drei
shows gespielt und die beste show wäre
eigentlich alle drei shows zusammen weil
ok verstehe mannheim war nicht
ausverkauft
münster und erfurt schon und die leute
wann unfassbar bei den ersten zwei shows
in mannheim auch unseren main haben
haben wir aber am besten gespielt aber
das publikum war total verhalten also es
ist total schwer zu sagen das ist immer
so ein zusammenspiel
ist es manchmal perfekt vielleicht nicht
gut genug weil es zu perfekt ist kann es
sein dass das publikum das gar nicht so
goutiert
ja ich wusste vor sieben jahren mehr als
vor zwei jahren als ich das stück die
perfektion geschrieben haben
darum geht viel zu schön und perfekt um
eigentlich wahr zu werden also dass das
da ist schon durchaus was dran glaube
ich dinge sind langweilig wenn sie
perfekt sind
wenn ihr live eingespielt habe ärgert
man sich dann nicht trotzdem mal wenn
man die stück gehört
das hätten wir trotzdem hätte ich am
liebsten korrigiert oder macht ihr es
dann spielt er so oft live ein bis er
genug zusammen habe was ihr zusammen
sein kann oder was und wie macht man
freut sich über die kleinen fehler
später also doch ja also augen fall habe
das was wir beim labyrinth haben wir
jeden jeden fehler ausgemerzt
dadurch hatte nichts platz irgendwie ein
bisschen rum zu wackeln oder um zu
feiern oder so und jetzt
ich freue mich hier und da wenn mal wenn
ich merke dass ist das ist nicht ganz
perfekt und wir vielleicht war die seite
nicht ganz hundertprozentig gestimmt
oder sowas welche welche band will man
denn sehen die die die komplett perfekt
klingt ja so oder oder auch diese ganzen
ami produktion also auch diese green day
platten ohne das war eigentlich so eine
geile band aber es klingt alles
mittlerweile viele plastik band findet
was sagen gibt es dann eine reaktion die
sache ja ihr seid wieder back to beruf
auf jeden fall dass ich meine schönheit
dass es jetzt mit abstand das
erfolgreichste album ist genau macht das
schon bei 122 den charts und dass das
ist dann schon eine sehr schöne
bestätigung und auch von den von den
feedback was wir kriegen ist wirklich so
geil endlich wieder back to hus wobei es
aber auch dann wieder leute gibt die
sagt labyrinthe war das beste album von
euch ob machbar ist okay das schöne ist
ja auch irgendwie dass man das alles
selber nicht steuern kann ein labyrinth
ich finde das ist gar nicht schlecht so
selber aber es war halt auch einfach so
dass ich jetzt bei diesem album viel
mehr zu erzählen hatte und das merken
die leute natürlich auch und irgendwie
sind wir mit diesem album auch viel
selbstbewusster und auch das merken die
leute und vielleicht stellen wir in zwei
jahren fest das labyrinth aber
eigentlich viel besseres album ist kann
er auch sein aber wenn man prozent
selbstbewusstsein rausgeht habe ich
immer das gefühl hat merken die leute
wir gehen vielleicht eine hand gute
frage jeder 1000 mal gefragt
aber ist ja wirklich für dich ein
entscheidendes ding ja das ist jetzt
zweieinhalb jahre her dass ich beim
videodreh irgendwie fünf meter stürzte
auf den betonboden und dem umständen
entsprechend bin ich ganz gut dabei
wieder spielte auf der tour so viel
gitarre wie eigentlich schon seit ganz
langer zeit primär und also über die
hälfte der stücke des spiels jetzt mit
und so war für mich ein riesen
erfolgserlebnis das ist aber auch nur so
weil ich mich selber quasi um die
physiotherapie gekümmert habe
physiotherapeut der mittlerweile ein
guter freund ist der ist jetzt die ganze
zeit mit auf tour und ich mache halt
viel so also richtig zusatzaufgabe qual
absolut ja ich kann das handgelenk halt
nicht so weit drehen lange nicht so weit
wie das erste am gelenk und beim gitarre
spielen brauch ich halt genau diese
bewegung und da bin ich auch noch lange
nicht da wo ich hin will
da madsen brüder sascha und sebastian
merz erfahrung musik ein konzert
manchmal extrem sport ist gut die der
profi gamer erzählt beim gaming auch
manchmal der fall ist der puls genau in
die bereiche eines profisportlers geht
und auch sehr lustig die haudegen die
mit rund ehrlicher musik aus
leidenschaft in die top ten gekommen
sind und warum das der fall ist das
erzählen sie also dass oder dass ihr
könnt euch jetzt aussuchen
viel spaß dabei und ansonsten bis dann
verbrannt